I can't even tell people the right day
sorry ash villians but thank you for
saying good morning to hang so Hank as
you can see from the Tippie odometer
he's gone so please don't fall please
don't call success
I am almost 250,000 unfortunately almost
doesn't count I've been able to improve
my fashion sense during signing madness
significantly by wearing this t-shirt
designed by a nerdfighter and for sale
now at dftba.com but Hank this t-shirt
is a little different from previous
t-shirts because all of our royalties
associated with the shirt will go to
what you've been calling the fund which
is good thinking because if we call it a
fun then maybe rich people will think
it's a hedge fund and like put money in
it and then we can be like sorry instead
of getting a return on your investment
we're going to decrease worldsuck so
like you may remember that in the
halcyon days of brotherhood 2.0 we
created this fund called the foundation
to decrease worldsuck and people could
donate to the fund and then we would
like distribute the money in ways that
decreased world saw-like sometimes we'd
give money to Save the Children and then
one time we paid for two nerdfighters a
nerdfighter like to take the train to
meet each other IRL one of whom later
became a massive web Liberty well as
part of the project for awesome 2011 we
are bringing back the foundation to
decrease worldsuck but this time no
stupid stuff in short nerdfighteria as a
community is going to put together a pot
of money and then we are going to choose
together how best to spend that money to
decrease the most worldsuck we're going
to be forced to prioritize our resources
to try to address the biggest problems
that we face as a species hold on Hank I
have to show you my paper jogger behold
at the amazing electro jog of amazing
which lines up stacks of papers
perfectly so that you can stick them in
boxes it is an incredible invention one
of the great inventions of all time
I think I'm just gonna say the single
greatest gift that electricity gave us
the electro job taking her phone her
name Brian came up to me at a signing
and he was like hey do you need a paper
jogger I have one and I was like I guess
I don't know our paper joggers useful
they are the most useful thing ever
created by man sorry I'm very excited
about my electro jog it saved me like 40
hours in the last two days which is good
because in the next 24 hours I have to
sign 5,000 books speaking of which I'm
going to leave you now but not before I
show you the amazing painting behind me
please don't look at this
it's a French llama and I'm riding it
wearing a swinging down Swilly poopers
Jersey and there's Henry and a Yeti and
then at the bottom it says The
Adventures of John Green most of my
adventures are indeed like this I I just
noticed that the llama is smoking very
French just another example of going to
nerdfighter and getting nothing except
for an awesome community thank you guys
so much for all of your support as I
have signed these books I did enjoy the
calendar for the day here is the
calendar it's happy Rock this is one of
those videos that is gonna completely
alienate new viewers like he's married
to a Yeti and he and his kid ride smokey
llamas and he's trying to steal our
money through some Ponzi scheme
involving t-shirts it's all true that
and more and you only have to watch 894
vlogbrothers videos for total
comprehension I guess also you need to
watch the swirly poopers and some of the
Hank and Kathryn play and I mean you
gotta join tumblr you just moved to the
Internet it's great here we get to live
inside where the weather is always
awesome